et le match à peine terminée des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
de supporters ont envahi les champs
elysées une fête comme la france n'en
avait pas connu ditto depuis la
libération
une communion totale de tout un peuple
olivier caroff et à lever tulard jamais
l'arc de triomphe n'aura si bien porté
son nom
sous l'oeil des géants de l'équipe de
france
un million et demi de personnes hier
soir sur les champs elysées
toute une nuit blanche pour voir la vie
en bleu
le rêve est devenu réalité et les
brésiliens qui savent l'effet que ça
fait les ont accompagnés pour danser on
a même trouvé mieux que la samba
une telle marée humaine c'était du
jamais vu depuis près d'un demi-siècle
le même drapeau pour tous et à chacun
son livre
de toute façon personne n'a été oublié
même pas la mascotte surtout pas
l'entraîneur
mais dès les premières minutes de fait
paris s'était déjà choisi un libérateur